dear lucas dear friends
of the european society for pediatric
oncology
in a year of pandemic we've all been
reminded
that science saves lives the world's
best hopes lie in the hands of doctors
biologists
researchers who are racing to develop
vaccines
against the virus and
when we first heard that a vaccine
against covet 19 had been developed
i thought of the famous quote by
churchill he said
never was so much owed by so many
to so few end of quote
we owe so much to researchers
and i want the european union to always
be at their site with all the support
they need
because they are at our side against
coronavirus
and against all other diseases
in 2020 over 1 million europeans died of
cancer
twice as many as the victims of
coronavirus
and still last year more than 15 000
european children were diagnosed with
cancer i was
13 years old when my little sister
eva benita died of cancer
she was just 11 years old
two years before she died her pain
started
it was an endless odyssey from
specialist to specialist
until after months the cause of her pain
was diagnosed
a reticulosarcoma a rare cancer
for my family the diagnosis was a bolt
out of the blue
all of a sudden our calm was shattered
the days were filled with fear and the
nights with
tears back then in
1971 there was nothing
the doctors could do to save her
but since then research has progressed
so
much diagnosis are much more precise
new classes of cancer drugs have been
discovered
and this can make the difference between
life and death
for thousands of children
and this is why the childhood cancer
awareness day
is so important research
saves lives
it is with this confidence in science
that one year ago we started working on
a new plan
against cancer we consulted doctors
researchers but also patients families
and survivors we received over 200
contributions from the pediatric cancer
community
and today i am proud to announce
that we have just adopted our proposal
for europe's beating cancer plan
it is a plan to put innovation and new
technologies
at the service of cancer care
it is a plan for prevention and early
detection
and crucially it includes a new
initiative called helping children with
cancer
the initiative will target the specific
challenges of pediatric cancers
for instance by the time they are
diagnosed
80 of pediatric cancers have already
spread to other
parts of the body and this must
change so the initiative
will focus on rapid detection and early
diagnosis
together with treatment and care
it will be supported by our research
program horizon europe
and together with the funding will also
come
policy and legislative measures
survivors of pediatric cancer face
specific challenges and almost one-third
of them
suffer severe long-term consequences
the initiative will create a cancer
survivor smart card
and a eu network
for youth cancer survivors
this is precisely to monitor the
survivors health
through the years and help them build a
new life
together we can give children with
cancer
a better chance together we can make a
difference
for children and for their families
for research for millions of europeans
who are
fighting for their life
thank you for joining